So the big news this weekend, of
course, was that Donald Trump was
acquitted in a second impeachment trial.
No president has ever been impeached twice.
Donald Trump has been impeached twice. And
now in both subsequent impeachment trials,
remember the House impeach as the Senate
tries, Trump has been acquitted in both trials.
And to convict on impeachment, you need two
thirds of vote to convict in the Senate,
all 100 senators being present. That means that on
Saturday, 67 Senate votes were needed and they got
only 57. That's all 50 Democrats, including newly
minted Democratic Senators John USCIRF and Raphael
Warnock, radical liberal Raphael Warnock, that
guy, remember him? That includes the two of them
reminding us of the importance of those January
5th primaries getting to 50 and then seven
Republicans voting to convict. Those were Richard
Burr, Bill Cassidy, Susan Collins, Lisa Murkowski,
Mitt Romney, Ben Sasse and Pat Toomey. We will
talk about why those seven a little bit later.
But 57 is not 67. Simple math tells us that.
And so Donald Trump did end up acquitted. Now,
not a surprise. We knew all along that it would go
this way. But one of the really wacky things that
happened is that Senate minority leader no longer
majority leader, Senate Minority Leader Mitch
McConnell, voted not guilty and then immediately
took the floor to give a defiant and detailed
speech about how Donald Trump did incite the riot
and did incite the violence and the insurrection.
And we're going to look at some clips here.
Mitch McConnell, moments after voting not guilty,
making as good a case as the House impeachment
managers about Donald Trump's guilt, about Donald
Trump's responsibility, about Donald Trump's
culpability for the insurrection and the riots
that took place on January 6th. But he
voted not guilty. Let's get into it.
There's no question that President Trump
is practically and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day. No question
about the people who stormed this building,
believed they were acting on
the wishes and instructions
of their president and having that believe was a
foreseeable consequence of the growing crescendo
of false statements, conspiracy
theories and reckless hyperbole,
which the defeated president kept shouting
into the largest megaphone on planet Earth.
The issue is not only the president's
intemperate language on January six.
It is not just his endorsement of remarks in
which an associate urged, quote, trial by combat.
It was also the entire manufactured
atmosphere of looming catastrophe,
the increasingly wild myths myth about a reverse
landslide election that was somehow being stolen
from secret, cuz I mean a total and complete
indictment of Donald Trump's actions.
But so why vote not guilty, Mitch?
And here, Mitch McConnell explains.
If President Trump were still in office,
I would have carefully considered whether
the House managers proved there specific
charge by the strict criminal standard.
The president's speech probably was not. However,
however, in the context of impeachment, the Senate
might have decided this was acceptable shorthand
for the reckless actions that preceded the riot.
But in this case, the question is moot because
former President Trump Trump is constitutionally
not eligible for conviction.
Now, this is a close question.
No doubt Donald Trump was the president when the
House voted, though, not when the House chose.
To deliver the papers, and there is
basically the explanation, McConnell
going on to say that since the punishment
for impeachment is removal from office
and Donald Trump is out of office, that this was
not a proper impeachment. They cannot convict as
a matter of procedure, is what Mitch McConnell is
arguing now in saying that Mitch McConnell misses
a number of important details.
The first detail is that a week ago today,
last Monday, we had a full day of
debate about whether the trial was OK
and whether the Senate had jurisdiction to try a
former president. And they voted and settled that
issue 56 to 44. But McConnell won't let it go. The
idea of how the Senate works is that as a body,
the Senate dealt with that question. It wasn't
unanimous. Mitch McConnell was one of the 44
who believed that the Senate did not
have that right. But as a body and again,
if you want to say how you know the Senate is not
a legal body, so why is the Senate even voting on
the constitutionality of the proceedings? They
chose to and they decided that, yes, 56 to 44
they can do the trial. Meaning if they determine
the person did what they're accused of doing,
they can say guilty, but McConnell doesn't care.
So McConnell is using an already adjudicated issue
to say that's why I voted not guilty. Second, it's
not just removal from office that is being debated
and voted on and is the punishment. It is also
barring Trump from running again, a punishment
which could be meted out. But Mitch McConnell
chooses not to mention that and only focus on
removal from office. So a truly pathetic attempt
by Mitch McConnell to play both sides. He gets his
not guilty vote in and appeases the trumpets. He
denounces the actions of Trump appeasing the more
sane Republicans. And on he goes, as he has
been doing for year after year after year.
Impeachment manager Madelene Dean noticed how
bizarre of a situation it was. Mitch McConnell
voting not guilty and then speaking 90 percent
about why Trump is guilty and then mentioning.
But he's out of office. So I had to vote not
guilty. Take a look at this Madelyne Dean clip.
It was powerful to hear the fifty seven guilty.
And then it was puzzling to hear and see
Mitch McConnell stand and say not guilty and then
minutes later stand again and say he was guilty of
everything. History will remember that statement
of speaking out of two sides of his mouth.
Now, different Republican senators have
been citing different reasons for why
they voted not guilty, most of them some
some taking the Mitch McConnell approach
about procedure. Others saying Trump didn't
really do the incitement. But really,
it's just political expediency, because when you
look at the Republicans who did vote to convict,
you start to get a picture of what's going on
here. Lisa Murkowski knows she doesn't need to be
on Trump side to win in Alaska, so she's free to
do whatever she wants. Ben Sasse has never really
cared about party approval, and he's taken hits
from the Republican Party and he doesn't seem to
care. So that's Ben Sasse. Cassidy is in Louisiana
where there are no standard party primaries. He
doesn't have to worry about that. Mitt Romney,
OK, after the meeting where he had the frogs legs
and thought maybe Trump would make him secretary
of state after that, Romney really hasn't cared.
And we know he doesn't need Donald Trump's support
in Utah because Utah Republicans are some of the
most anti Trump Republicans in the country.
Pat Toomey and Richard Burr, they're retiring,
so they don't care. And then Susan Collins has
this more moderate constituency in Maine. So
these aren't coincidences that these are the seven
Republicans who voted to convict. These were not
seven Republicans who believe that Trump
was guilty and 43 who did not. This was
probably several dozen Republicans who believe
Trump was guilty, seven of which seven of whom
have particular circumstances that allow them to
actually vote their conscience rather than what
we saw from many Republicans. And, of course,
you have many Republicans who genuinely believe
that this was all a, you know, unnecessary
and unfair and all of that, I'm guessing.
Well, I don't know which ones those are. I
guess Ted Cruz would be one, maybe Josh Haley,
some others. So that's that. Trump acquited 57
to 43, a majority, a majority saying guilty,
but needing that two thirds vote, Trump acquitted.
And let's now get into some of the other
interesting moments from the last day of the
trial, the last couple of days of the trial.